alright guys that's so exciting action
I'm gonna go sleep in that giant uterus
in my garage we're doing well we are
doing well we're going along singing a
song that's so much oh you're right this
is broken
hey Kimberly I can't talk right now I
don't know what the girls are calm down
Brantley the girls are with me where the
strip club Oh which one gotta tell me
male or female
you shouldn't say nailed it around a
pregnant lady though in front of your
mom I nailed it
yeah cut action and cut
hi I'm practicing you know I'm the
director of the movie Mother's Day my
name is Carrie Marshall and what you're
about to see is the guru who who are you
or did it did it did it me oh my
goodness what would we do that obvious
mmm should I got a discount for that one
I usually don't say do anything until
someone says action so doing this it's
very stressful and it's a lot of things
go wrong and you got a rush and when you
do that sometimes there's mistakes I
just don't like feeling so replaceable
hey Liv is ready Anna was horrible older
in the garage popping the bubble wrap on
the top of the bubbles in the bubble
wrap in the float sorry we did okay yeah
next thing you know we'll be saving the
it pie got some info one more time mmm
sorry I know the lion I just got for
klimt Oh go back yeah I expect more out
of you can we do those again just right
here let's just go back to that one part
all the way from Lubbock Texas that was
a little bit wrong that what you're good
once you get weak a mom let's close the
garage three full turn around kiss me
again
don't worry totally not a hard job every
movie has unique challenges and we had
oz we had sound problems first we had
insects I'm the mother you don't just
get in on technicality okay
I mean there's so many sounds happening
whoa
you hear that fly like an engine oil let
me just tell you something no no no I
just did all right mum Shh
then we had trains how about that train
folks we got that here in Atlanta yeah
we do Tuesday then we had plenty of
planes and by for the plane comes a
plane plane plane plane gonna kill me oh
plane plane yeah Apple 60 Boeing take
seven me too two days ago birthday
cruise - lets go hey we had plenty of
water
all day work and the rain
we worked some long days and once a
while the crew has a level of steam and
the actors had a let off some steam and
we did it in very different ways
let's rip this shop
and the Emmy goes mmm Margo Mars hey get
away from the vagina hi I'm Larry Miller
but in a way aren't we all
hi mom hi mom hi mom
hey mothers
Mother's Day mom
Margaret market hey Mark happy Mother's
Day happy Mother's Day love you love you
too
do the mother of me and the mother must
seem to be child happy Mother's Day
marker nailed it nailed it
now that love your mom now if excuse me
I need to get in the character I'm
Cameron Esposito and I'm Sara taki our
favorite moms Dianne mom only ones %
love you have had the other day we want
to wish you a Happy Mother's Day I've
always wanted to do this yeah
happy Mother's Day in my house every day
is Mother's Day so she's gonna love this
movie happy Mother's Day to me hi
everybody hello Go Go Go Go we love you
I really enjoyed shooting Mother's Day
in Atlanta I've been in Atlanta quite a
while
I like Atlanta but I think it's time to
go home
happy birthday
happy Mother's Day
ever happy Mother's Day happy Mother's
Day happy Mother's Day everyone
happy Mother's Day
have another thing
okay hit the thing
Oh